insomma tutti ragazzo allora questo
compito diverso devo farlo assolutamente
c'è nel senso potevo non farlo dove
dovevo farlo assolutamente ci hanno
deciso di youtube è infatti deciso di
lanciare un esperimento a globale
veramente interessante che si chiama
life in a day che cos'è lo stelo subito
le licenze scozzese kevin macdonald
curino infatti le regioni documentario
che realizzerà fruttare molto
imbottigliare di venanzo persone tra le
varie strutture
questo documentario finirà al sundance
film festival con l'importantissimo
evento per essere stato il mondiale
indignati che ha deciso di produrre
tutto ciò ridley scott
se non sapete chi sia questo tizio non
scrivetelo nei commenti che ci fate
porta figura come fare delle occasioni
di essere inseriti in questo
documentario è facilissimo e che il 24
luglio sapere di caricare un video che
mostra così un pezzetto la vostra
giornata ai che sia minori di dieci
minuti mi raccomando mostrate che ne so
il progetto che fate per andare al
lavoro insomma ragazzi qualsiasi cosa
che rientrerà vostra quotidianità non
dovete mettervi nulla può essere un
giorno triste felice e tranquillo di
ansia delusione renali na cicoria cactus
orsetti gommosi ben secondi se volete
inserite anche dei contenuti che
mostrino cosa vi piace o cos'è
straordinario del paese nel quale vivete
in alternativa potreste rispondere anche
alle seguenti domande cosa temete oggi
cosa invece vi sta andando alla grande
cosa che fa ridere cosa avete in tasca
che tempo fa ma anche qui c'è sentitevi
liberi di dire qualsiasi cosa che mi
frulla in testa quel giorno a mi
raccomando non usate in musica o clip di
programmi tv che poi col copyright
comunque questa è veramente una
grandissima occasione
e poi sono contento di potermi
presentare questo progetto